[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec le docteur michel yao
responsable des opérations d'urgence de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
afrique pour contrer le qu'ovide 19
docteur michelle yeoh bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour telle est la situation sur le
terrain docteur up la situation pelé
terrain évolue très rapidement
c'est une maladie contagieuse qui se
reproduit très rapidement or il faut dit
que en afrique nous avons passé
maintenant le cas de dix mille cas avec
environ 500 un peu plus de 500 dessins
nous avons pour toute l'afrique a su les
54 pays
il y a seulement deux pays qui n'ont pas
encore rapporté de cas il y aller les
auteurs et les comores et est donc
classée il la maladie s'est répandue
pratiquement dans tous les pays
d'afrique
un parmi ces payer il y à peu près 17
pays qui ont déjà rapporté un plus de
100 cas et dans certains pays la
contamination locale se multiplient de
jour en jour et donc c'est une situation
qui reste préoccupante et pour laquelle
il y à des actions urgentes de de
mobilisation de prise en compte par des
autorités politiques et administratives
fort pour mettre à l'échelle une réponse
minitieuse et une réponse rigoureuse par
rapport à cette situation
on va parler des réponses mais juste sur
les chiffres officiels je crois qu'ils
proviennent du centre africain de
prévention et de lutte contre les
maladies de l'union africaine est ce que
ces chiffres sont réalistes
comment et effectuer le recensement des
cas et des décès au il s'agit d' équipes
qui travaillent le plus souvent des
équipes de différents ministères de la
santé
localement dans quelques pays et appuyer
aussi par des épidémiologistes de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
sont pas partout
à cause des limitations des voyages dans
certains pays elles ont demandé mais on
l'a pas donc ce sont des chiffres qui
sont d'abord validé par les autorités
nationales et par la suite transmis à l'
oms selon le règlement un sanitaire et
donc les premiers niveaux de
vérification ce sont les pays
un mourant nous les recevant à si nous
avons des préoccupations particulières
nous les expliquons et ceux ci se faire
à travers un mécanisme qui est très
réglementée qui est le règlement
sanitaire international alors s'agissant
de la stratégie de riposte face aux
coville 19h en afrique est ce que vous
pouvez nous parler de ce plan d'urgence
mis en place par l oms et l'union
africaine homme se plaint il s'agit en
fait de pouvoir se mobilisent et
mobiliser davantage de ressources
il y a plusieurs domaines de réponse
cela par des éléments de détection que
sont les aspects de laboratoire avec
l'union africaine
il y a eu plusieurs projets de formation
et d'équipement de laboratoire à travers
l'approvisionnement de réactifs mais
aussi d'équipements
les besoins sont encore énormes parce
qu'il y a un besoin de décentraliser ce
processus là pour tester davantage parce
que c'est la crise sinon en avance à la
règle il y a aussi l'appui en termes de
mise en place des structures de prise en
charge
on voit ce qui se passe en europe il
faut anticiper il faut se préparer et
donc comment nous aidons les payer en
termes d'équipement équipements de
protection pour les agents de santé
ainsi que leur formation et il y à bien
sur les aspects sensibilisation et de
communication donc 16 ce sont ces
aspects là pour lesquels nous essayons
de mutualiser nos efforts mais nous
essayons aussi de mobiliser les états à
l'union africaine
prat aussi le volet politique le volet
sensibilisation des responsables des
chefs d'état mais aussi des autorités
sanitaires
pour que les actions appropriées et
surtout une certaine l'appropriation de
la réponse puisse se faire à un haut
niveau pour que les choses puissent être
exécutés parce que maintenant il s'agit
d'une course contre la montre comment
éviter le pire scénario alors justement
l'om est alerte face au pire en afrique
quelles sont les prévisions et le
difficile d'avoir des prévisions à
exactement ce que nous observons c'est
que les chiffres augmentent assez
rapidement harry dans les trois derniers
jours nous avons pratiquement doublé et
de l'expérience que nous avons eu des
les autres continents en c'est
pratiquement pas le même contexte mais
si on se base là dessus on peut
facilement à partir de ces chiffres qui
sont multipliées par deux en trois jours
du sytral quatre jours ces chiffres pour
surtout pour certains pays peut
facilement être multiplié par 5 passes
est donc c'est un peu cela parce que on
a fait que les prévisions doivent tenir
compte aussi de comtesse la géographique
il y à des endroits difficiles d'accès
et donc la propagation ne peut pas aller
aussi vite
il y a aussi une certaine promiscuité
dans certaines villes il y à des
maladies qu'ils pouvaient 1 pourrait en
fait facilité ou bien à avoir un impact
sur l'issue du coronavirus notamment en
terme de gravité que ce sont des
maladies comme le vih a le paludisme au
même des états comme la malnutrition et
la tuberculose est donc tous ses effets
la faune que à une modélisation est
difficile et il faut tenir compte de
tous ces facteurs là nous y travaillons
encore nous avons vu la modélisation
fait par plusieurs institutions
universitaires qui sont d'ailleurs en
larmes en est bien sûr si rien n'est
fait en ccd scénario qui pourrait être
possible mais il est très difficile pour
nous d'avancer des estimation exacte on
y travaille alors comment et avec quels
moyens les hôpitaux les personnels
soignants font face à la pandémie sur le
continent or seul camp
sinon les moyens utilisés sont très
limitées et c'est cela notre
préoccupation et c'est ce pourquoi il ya
un appel à la solidarité malheureusement
les pays africains ont un accès limité
au marché international qui procure tous
ces aspects là et est donc et il est
important que l'on puisse en fait mettre
un mécanisme pour permettre
l'approvisionnement l'om s y aide aux
mères les intrants que nous réussissons
à mobiliser sont très limités il y a
aussi des aspects des disponibilités de
cargos impro transporté donc sans une
aide extérieure il serait difficile à
l'afrique d'avoir tous ces moyens qui
sont nécessaires l'autre élément aussi
pour lesquelles nous encourageons les
états s'est accélérée les formations il
faut vraiment mettre à niveau informer
les professionnels de santé il y en a
plusieurs qui sont déjà contaminés dans
certains pays et il faut les former et
former vite et en grand nombre je
parlais tout à l'heure de penser déjà à
un scénario où on aurait une
contamination massif et qu'on montre qui
pourrait nécessiter la contribution de
plusieurs médecins de plusieurs
infirmiers à tous les niveaux que ce
soit dans les capitales ou en milieu
rural comme en europe on risque de
manquer de masques de respirateurs la
situation là bas on n'a fait que des
estimations qu'on a on enregistre en
termes de lits disponibles
on a peut-être un peu plus de 6000 pour
toute l'afrique donc c'est une capacité
limitée dans certains pays on a moins
d'une vingtaine de lits de rente m2 hors
service de réanimation et donc il faut
absolument penser à d'autres mécanismes
non seulement un investissement local
pour augmenter ses capacités avec des
sujets temporaire en mobilisant des
bâtiments en pensant déjà les
approvisionner
ne serait ce même qu'avec des matériaux
au niveau local on
on fait cela pour des maladies comme le
choléra roues ont construit des centres
de choléra avec des tentes avec des lits
en bois et donc il faut y penser
il y a aussi le fait qu'il faut
s'assurer que 1 pour rappel pour
l'afrique c'est tous les cas critiques
en ce serait très difficile
décentraliser donc comment comme à
charge de façon précoce qu'on m'a
détecté rapidement
et là encore l'afrique se retrouve aussi
face à la difficulté d'approvisionnement
à un réactif
je parlais tout à l'heure de solidarité
et d'appui
c'est vraiment important pour éviter
en fait pour faire face au pire si cela
devenait temps à arriver et vos
observations encore une fois sur le
terrain concernant les symptômes au
niveau des populations
or pour le moment il y à quelques d'un
millier de cannes c or il y a un profil
mais ce difficile de tirer des
conclusions en ce moment en main les
quelques desserts qu'on a eus sont liées
aussi à une combinaison de facteurs de
gens qui ont d'autres maladies comme le
diabète ou l'hypertension en mai ce sont
des éléments qu'on doit suivre
et ça ça me fait aborder aussi le fait
qu'on à a besoin aussi de mobiliser les
chercheurs en afrique
vous travaillez si ces domaines là c'est
une maladie qui est un méconnu et on ne
connaît pas encore la réaction de cette
maladie au niveau de la fiq donc il faut
absolument des recherches pour
consolider des connaissances qui puisse
permettre de changer les approches au
fur et à mesure que à l'épidémie avance
donc pour le moment la tendance est que
des personnes un peu plus âgés ou qu'ils
ont d'autres maladies soient beaucoup
plus sujets à des formes sévères et des
formes critique
justement le continent africain
concentre une population très jeune -
vieillissante que dans les pays du nord
c'est un atout clairement vous pensez or
c'est un atout mais il ya aussi d'autres
facteurs en prendre
prendre en compte la la jeunesse
pourrait faire qu'on pourrait avoir un
si on tient compte de l'évolution de la
maladie actuelle on pourrait avoir moins
de cas sévères mais ceci peut être
facilement balancé par le fait qu' il y
à aussi certaines maladies qui
pourraient entraîner des formes graves
et on a une fois depuis valence comparé
aux autres continents une forme grave
une forme pardon de tuberculose une
prévalence de la tuberculose nous avons
aussi à des maladies comme le vih sida
qui a fait l'humanité et je parlais tout
à l'heure de la malnutrition qu'il a
chez l'enfant diminue aussi la capacité
de réaction de l'organisme donc tous ces
facteurs là peuvent contrebalancer le
fait qu'on ait une population jeune même
si cela reste aussi un atout par rapport
à ce qu'on a observé depuis le début
selon une étude de l'institut pasteur et
du centre de la recherche nationale
scientifique le cnrs les africains et
les européens
elles répondent différemment aux
infections est ce que l'om s prend cette
donnée en ligne de compte si oui cela
signifie quoi face au co vie de 19 pour
les populations africaines homme je
parlais tout à l'heure de nécessité de
rechercher il faut que cela soit en fait
consolidé par une recherche qui
accompagnent malheureusement cette
maladie est nouvelle et pendant qu'on y
reprend on apprendra beaucoup plus il
est très tôt de pouvoir en fait donner
des éléments de réponse ou bien
d'affirmations par rapport à ces
différentes hypothèses
au regard de votre expérience dans la
lutte contre ebola est ce qu'on peut
comparer ou pas du tout par ailleurs
l'expérience acquise dans la lutte
contre la fièvre hémorragique mais aussi
contre le paludisme est ce que cette
expérience elle peut être utile face aux
copies de 10,9 au oui de notre
expérience en matière de baux là je
pense que les connaissances acquises
vont certainement aider à l'une des
premières choses qu'on a pris des
bollards c'est que sans les communautés
il est très difficile de contrôler ce
genre de maladies infectieuses
parce que les mesures de santé publique
exige une certaine adhésion et pour que
la communauté puisse adhérer il faut que
cette communauté soit bien informé qu'on
puisse leur assigner des rôles et des
responsabilités et ça c'est vraiment une
des choses apprises l'autre chose aussi
c'est se préparer à être mieux préparés
l'afrique
or on a déjà des cas mais on peut se
préparer à la phase suivante à une phase
d'aggravation et mieux on est préparé
mieux on a à une réponse cohérente à une
réponse sans panique une réponse qui est
basé sur des des évidences et donc ça
c'est l'autre aspect le troisième point
de l'expérience d'ebola c'est que en
afrique on aura probablement besoin de
partenaire qui puisse aider à augmenter
les capacités de réponse
le système de santé actuel ans très peu
de capacité pour la prise en charge de
corona on doit continuer à suivre les
femmes qui accouchent sur les enfants
malades et en même temps faire face à au
corona et 100 des partenaires comme des
ong qui mettent des centres de
traitement
cela pourrait être difficile et le
dernier point c'est l'analyse et
l'évidence qui permettent de réajuster
chaque fois la réponse donc c'est toutes
ces connaissances à un petit pied un
avantage à pousser repayer africain et
pour lesquelles on essaie de partager
pour que cela puisse être mis au profit
du comité 19 sur le port du masque
docteur michelle yeoh l'om et stations
que ce n'est pas la solution miracle
est ce que c'est le cas dans les pays
africains où la distanciation social
n'est pas évidente au lait mars se
feront partie d'une solution globale
le premier élément c'est s'assurer que
on est uni gêne c'est une hygiène des
mains qui puisse faire mieux on ne se
contaminent pas en touchant peut-être
pas méga le visage l'autre aspect c'est
basée sur l'évidence qu'une personne qui
a contaminé qui toussent ou éternuent
peut contaminer une autre personne donc
pour ces personnes
alors c'est la première recommandation
de l'om est que ces personnes là puisse
porter des masques
maintenant l'évolution de l'épidémie
montre aussi qu'on pourrait avoir des
personnes asymptomatiques
et donc si les moyens permettent c'est
que ces personnes là qui sont à hao
risque est ici dans un milieu de
promiscuité que ce soit dans les
transports publics ou un milieu où on
pourrait se retrouver à proximité
dans ce cas le port de masques pourrait
être indiqués la grosse difficulté c'est
les disponibilités sur le marché on se
réjouit que la recherche permettent
maintenant de fait quelques
recommandations notamment dans des
fabrications de masse locale mais la
priorité reste aussi la protection du
personnel médical
ce personnel là on n'a pas le choix on
doit avoir des masques qu'ils puissent
effectivement les protéger dans
l'exercice de la fonction parce qu'ils
travaillent à proximité de personnes qui
sont déjà contaminés
donc la position de l'om est dans les
disponibilités actuelles protéger le
personnel médical protéger les autres
des personnes qui sont infectées et si
on a les moyens
dans les milieux de promiscuité pouvoir
porter dès mars parce qu'il ya aussi des
formes asymptomatiques qui dans une
certaine pour discuter pour favoriser la
contamination et le confinement sur un
continent les populations vivent en
grande partie dans l'informel est ce que
c'est une stratégie possible à sa
stratégie
difficile en afrique même en terme même
si en terme de santé publique c'est une
stratégie qui permet de limiter la
propagation d'une zone a hautement
contaminée par rapport à une zone qu'il
ne l'est pas encore mais ces mesures
pour que ce soit faisable en afrique
doivent être forcément accompagné et il
s'agit de mesures qui permettent aux
personnes qui vivent au jour le jour
d'avoir des moyens de survie on ne peut
pas confiné des populations dont une
grande proportion ne peut plus
approvisionné c'est très difficile que
cela puisse marcher
il faut aussi d'autres mesures notamment
d'assurer que ces populations confiné
ont accès à l'eau et aussi d'être des
intrants comme le savon pour se laver
les mains on le fait dans le cadre des
épidémies de choléra ou certains
partenaires notamment des ong installe
des points d'eau dans des endroits
difficiles des points de lavage de mains
en afrique qui sera difficile surtout
pour les familles où on a une très forte
promiscuité de limiter de d'éviter la
maladie au sein d'une même famille ce
sont des familles qui parfois dans dans
la même pièce mais ce qu'on peut limiter
ces la propagation à grande échelle dans
un quartier donné si il y à ces mesures
d'hygiène et surtout s'il ya un
mécanisme de détection précoce c'est
dans une famille une personne qui est
malade puis cet extrait est isolé
rapidement on pourrait éventuellement
protéger les autres donc en afrique il
s'agit pas d'un message générique ou
rester à la maison mais il faut
absolument accompagnée de mesures de
santé publique mais aussi d'autres
mesures d'approvisionnement en eau et
d'approvisionnement en intrants qui sont
nécessaires à cette réponse à son usage
de la chloroquine qui fait débat partout
dans le monde quelle est la position de
l'om est afrique son usage sur le
continent oh la la position de l'om mais
c'est une position basée sur les
standards
les standards qui entoure l'utilisation
ou de nouveaux médicaments ou des
indications nouvelle pour des
médicaments qui existent la chloroquine
résistèrent pour le paludisme dans la
plupart des pays mais l'indication pour
le coc vite est très peu connu à l'étape
initiale dans tous les niveaux de des
médicaments ou de nouvelles indications
cdd recherche initiale de que des gens
qui sont dans les laboratoires qui font
des essais qui ont des réponses plus ou
moins positif mais cela est très peu
pour faire une recommandation mondiale
il faut absolument qu'on puisse savoir à
quelle dose
le ce médicament est efficace sur le
court navire russe et est ce que à cette
dose efficace
est ce que cette hausse n'est pas nocif
à la personne qui l'utilisent et à ses
on a une maladie qui évolue en phase à
partir de quelle phase le médicament est
efficace ou ne l'est plus ce sont des
éléments à vraiment savoir avant
d'émettre une recommandation globale
donc la position de l'om est ce c'est
que c'est des médicaments qui ont
probablement des effets positifs mais
pour les utiliser il faut les faire à
travers un protocole un protocole qui
fait que cela ait approuvé par un comité
d'éthique pour qu'on puisse tester les
doses on puisse tester l'efficacité ou
l'innocuité à une certaine dose sur les
personnes et ses protocoles à doit être
aussi entouré de consentement des
personnes mais la façon dont cela est
présenté selon l'autorisent à 101 savoir
aussi d'éventuels effets secondaires
sans être totalement sûr à 100% de son
efficacité
et c'est seulement à une utilisation
organisés à travers des protocoles qui
permettront de recueillir des données
robuste et il se pose puisque il ya
plusieurs pays qui se laissait à travers
les protocoles on pourra peut-être
arriver à des recommandations formelles
mais pour le moment c'est notre position
c'est qu'il est très tôt
faire une recommandation d' usage massif
pour le traitement du corps vide docteur
michelle yeoh
merci je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable des opérations d'urgence de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
afrique merci pour cette grande
interview sur rtl france merci beaucoup
merci pour une grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver en podcast sur nos
réseaux sociaux et sur notre site rtl
france pointé des merci de votre
attention
à très bientôt
[Musique]